i mean we've been talking about who's
the best team in the league
now through five weeks when the question
should always be who's gonna end up
being the best team in the league
and yeah wait there's more wait i agree
there's more
they might be signing dez bryant and
look he might just be a name
he may not have anything left he didn't
look great you know when we last saw him
obviously and he had the achilles when
he signed with new orleans
but they don't have much receiver help
outside of marquis brown
so now they bring in dez bryant to their
practice squad
pending a physical and
that's what smart organizations do as
eric de casas said in a statement
we are not done building this thing so
we've been talking about the chiefs and
the steelers and the titans
and everybody in the mama except for the
ravens
who only go out and get a pro bowl
caliber pass rusher adding to an already
ridiculous defense man like you know
that's that's
i that excited me today i'm not even a
ravens fan but i was doing it
no you're right listen mike i'm with you
uh you talk about the front office and
of course
uh we would look at the front office you
know we nerd out on that stuff on team
building
so you look at what what they've done
there ozzie newsome
for a long time making the moves in the
general manager's seat and he turns it
over
to eric decosta so that and eric decosta
is doing a great job too
there is something in just the dna of
how
uh the ravens build their teams and
they've been doing it for a long time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe
for the latest news and highlights from
nbc sports